[Music]
all right here's a moment we end our
newscast with every night here at six
o'clock jeopardy warm up we get to see
which of our contestants knows the most
about las vegas our contestants tonight
all familiar to you brian loftus ted
florindo chris matthews guys who each
have 15 seconds to answer our clue and
again whoever wins tonight takes home
the title of the smartest anchor and
gets to give each other a hard time in
the hallway all right so let's start
tonight contestants you ready you got 15
seconds
[Laughter]
is tonight's clue for the gentleman and
the folks at home
the movie star
shot the conqueror and the nevada test
site in 1956
and was also the star of true
grit
who is the movie star we are looking for
15 seconds on the clock
big big movie star
back in the day huh big you say big yeah
yeah like lassie
last season
but it's not last night
not damon
okay i think 15 seconds is up
uh let's start with chris let's start
with you okay here we go how'd you do
who is this guy john wayne
well done chris matthews
guaranteed yes yes
guaranteed
ted florindo if my answer is on this qr
code if you scan qr code
you can actually it's actually i got
john
of course very good good job ted true
and we gave brian the answer going
to bring us home there we go
oh guys got it tonight well done did you
get it right at home